this video is kindly sponsored by
conflict of nations the free online
military themed pvp strategy game hey 42
here we all love a good prank there's
nothing quite like physically and
psychologically torturing the people we
love the most for a light bit of
entertainment
cling film over the toilet seat the
perfect jump scare that sends your
girlfriend into a cardiac arrest
impersonating an african prince who
infiltrated british warship with one of
england's most famous female authors
dressed as a man
wait
what
pranking is a thoroughly modern
phenomenon born out of social media and
the proliferation of the smartphone
in the victorian era when men were
chivalrous and gallant and women were
elegant charming and mercilessly
repressed
people were far too sensible for
anything as petty as pranking
or were they
because as it happens the greatest
prankster ever to have lived isn't some
millennial with an iphone and 50 million
youtube subscribers
he was a member of britain's social
elite who was born almost 150 years ago
do you have what it takes to lead a
nation
rally an army and ultimately dominate
the world
well now you can put your strategic
combat skills to the test by choosing a
real country to lead in modern global
warfare it's all down to your strategy
and how you take command
will you declare war on your neighbors
or forge alliances with other players in
order to overcome all 128 players in
real time in games that can take weeks
to complete my favorite part of conflict
of nations is the incredible attention
to detail in the beautifully designed
maps and the pvp battles are always fun
conflict of nations is available across
pc and mobile you can even play on the
same account on both devices to start
you off on your road to global
domination you can now get an exclusive
gift all you have to do is click on the
link in the description to get 13 000
goals and one month of premium
subscription for free
the offer is only available for 30 days
so hurry
on paper horace davia cole called to his
friends
isn't an obvious candidate for the
world's most brilliant prankster he's a
bit more downton abbey than trigger
happy tv if you see what i mean
for starters he came from a wealthy and
influential family who were so well
connected they made the rothschilds look
like the simpsons
cole's father was a major in the british
army his mother was an heiress related
to the earl of oxford his uncle would go
on to become the governor of the bank of
england and his sister married future
prime minister neville chamberlain in
keeping with his upbringing cole was
educated first at eaton the fanciest of
fancy pants schools in england and then
cambridge one of the most revered
universities in the world and yet
for all this pomp and circumstance
horace davier cole cared about one thing
and one thing only
pranking the living crap out of
everything that moved
his first major stunt took place when he
was an undergraduate at cambridge in
1905.
whilst browsing the paper one morning he
noticed that the sultan of zanzibar
would soon be visiting london on
official business to any other student
that would have been a mildly
interesting news article
but to horace davier cole
it was an opportunity after hastily
putting together a plan he sent a
telegram to the mayor of cambridge
claiming that the sultan's uncle was
planning on visiting the city the
following week
after recruiting his best friend adrian
stephen and a couple of other willing
accomplices cole then took a trip to a
renowned theatrical costume maker willie
clarkson who darkened their skin with
makeup and kitted them out in what they
assumed a zanzibar prince's uncle and
his entourage might wear
incidentally willie clarkson is famous
for making disguises both for scotland
yard and for many of london's most
notorious criminals
some also believe he may have been jack
the ripper but that's a story for
another video
it says a lot about the era that cole
thought blackface and some theater
costumes would be enough to fool anyone
into believing him and his friends were
actually african royalty
but it says even more about the era that
the disguises worked a treat
not only did an official delegation
including the may of cambridge himself
take the group around the city
the students were even given a private
tour of the very same university they
were attending at the time rumor has it
not even their own friends and
professors recognized them perhaps
because of his own grandiose upbringing
cole hated pomposity and arrogance in
all its forms which is why he made it
his unofficial mission in life to bring
some of britain's most important people
down a peg or two in perhaps his most
famous takedown of a public figure cole
challenged his one-time school friend
from his eaton days conservative mp
oliver locker lamson to a good
old-fashioned foot race down on london
street
apparently confident in his sprinting
ability cole even offered to give locker
lampson a 10-yard head start
i can only assume locker lamson wasn't
aware of cole's reputation as prank
master general at this point because he
foolishly took up the challenge
streaking out in front to make the most
of his head start
but before locker lamson could begin to
celebrate a certain victory a voice
called out behind him stop thief and
before he knew what was happening he'd
been tackled to the ground by a passing
policeman
locker lampson was furious
but that fury soon turned to disbelief
when the policeman asked him to turn out
his pockets and harris de villa cole's
solid gold pocket watch sneakily planted
before the race by cole himself
tumbled to the floor
as far as pranks go framing an innocent
member of parliament for a criminal
offence is pretty brutal but cole did
eventually admit he'd set the whole
thing up for a lark and locker lampson
was released without charge
not all of coles's pranks were aimed as
authority figures sometimes he just
wanted to watch the world burn
in one of his most outrageous escapades
he and a group of friends dressed up as
workmen and closed off piccadilly circus
with barriers not content to simply
disrupt the traffic at one of london's
busiest and most prestigious junctions
and possibly in order to make the whole
thing look a bit more legit
cole and his friends proceeded to start
digging trenches in the road at random
the prank was so convincing that local
police even lent a hand in redirecting
traffic
along with his signature brand of
undermining authority figures and sowing
general anarchy wherever he went
cole wasn't afraid of a little scandal
either he once strolled the streets of
london with the teat from a cow's udder
hanging out of his trouser fly
resembling uh well
i'll leave that up to your imagination
when a suitably large and angry crowd
had gathered around berating him for
indecency and threatening to call the
police
cole pulled out a pair of scissors
smiled a whined mischievous smile
and cut the udder clean off
they say the ensuing screams could be
heard halfway across the capital
historical opinion seems to be divided
on how we should view harris davier cole
some see him as an immature tough with
too much time on his hands who didn't
care who he hurt in the pursuit of a
cheap laugh
others see him as something of a hero a
man brave enough to recognize and mock
the absurdity of the privilege he was
born into whichever side you come down
on it's hard to deny the man had a
certain style before the opening night
of one of london's possessed west end
shows he arrived early and began giving
out tickets for free outside
but there was a catch
he would only give his complimentary
tickets to bald men
who would agree to one strange condition
what exactly that condition was
didn't become clear until later that
night
cole had only given tickets to men who
agreed to have a single letter written
on their heads
meaning the wealthiest patrons in the
expensive upper tiers were treated to
the word bollocks
spelt out on strategically placed bald
heads below them when the lights came up
at the end of the show
cole pulled off perhaps hundreds of
pranks during his lifetime
but today
he's known for one above all of us
the dreadnought hoax
it started with a request
one of cole's friends was in the navy
and he wanted coal to put his prodigious
pranking powers to use
to get one over on the officers on a
ship called hms dreadnought a ship that
just so happens to be by far the most
advanced vehicle of war on planet earth
at the time so how do you go about
pranking the officers in charge of the
world's greatest warship
i mean it's not like you can just stroll
on board a heavily armed military vessel
whenever you feel like it
well
not unless you're horista via coal for
the crowning prank of his career coal
drew on earlier experience particularly
his infamous prank at cambridge
involving the sultan of zanzibar's uncle
there were no convenient visits for many
foreign royals planned
so cole made one up it was about time
the prince of abyssinia which is today
ethiopia visited england
once again cole drew on his friends to
make the prank more convincing
there were six of them in total mostly
drawn from what would become known as
the bloomsbury group a collection of
esteemed english writers artists
intellectuals and philosophers who used
to hang out in bloomsbury london
along those roped in for the dreadnought
hoax were adrian stephen cole's partner
in crime for the cambridge prank
steven's sister virginia who you may
know by her married name virginia woolf
and the artist duncan grant
once again cole kicked things off with a
telegram this time to the
commander-in-chief of britain's entire
home fleet
announcing the imminent arrival of
several abyssinian princes who were keen
to take a look at hms dreadnought
in preparation for the big day cole paid
a visit to his old mate and costumia
willie clarkson the ripper to suitably
kits his friends out in princely robes
and blackface in case you're wondering
the handsome chap with her beard on the
left is legendary author virginia woolf
on the appointed day cole and his
friends went to paddington station in
london where coal claiming to be a
member of the british foreign office
demanded that a train be made ready to
take abyssinian royals to weymouth where
hms dreadnought was stationed
it's testament to cole's impressive
powers of persuasion as well as how
deeply entrenched class roles were at
the turn of the 20th century that the
station master at paddington complied it
once ordering that an opulent private
train be readied for the prince's
journey south
once again the theater garb and simple
makeup worked wonders when the friends
arrived in weymouth they were treated of
all the reverence their royal blood
demanded they were welcomed aboard hms
dreadnought to a full guard of honor
before being given an extensive private
tour of the british navy's most prized
asset
to make things more convincing the group
had even invented their own nonsense
language drawn from a swahili phrasebook
they'd studied on the train mixed with
latin and greek phrases they remembered
from university all of which meant that
in a scene so ridiculous it's hard to
believe it actually happened a famous
prankster one of the most important
english writers of all time a renowned
artist and several of their semi-famous
friends
were taken around the british navy's
most dangerous warship wearing fake
beards and theater costumes
spouting utter gibberish to one another
amongst the nonsense one of their
phrases really caught on
and the group could be heard muttering
bunga bunga in excited tones whenever
they were shown something particularly
impressive
to make the whole farce even more
ridiculous it turns out one of the
senior officers on the dreadnought was
commander willie fisher
who happens to be virginia and adrian's
cousin despite personally showing them
rounds the warship for several hours
at no point did commander fisher
recognize two members of his own family
one of whom was a woman wearing a fake
beard
the whole plan nearly came undone more
than once at one point it began to
drizzle and cole who was dressed in his
own clothes and playing the role of
translator was forced to make an excuse
to get the group below deck before their
crude makeup began to run
they were also offered a lavish meal but
figuring the fake beards wouldn't stand
up to prolonged chewing
cole hastily explains that the
abyssinians were only able to eat food
that had been specially prepared to
certain obscure religious standards
ultimately the group got through it
unscathed and it wasn't until the story
of the hoax appeared in the daily mail a
couple of days later that the navy had
any idea they'd been duped of course
this time things were a little more
serious
cole hadn't embarrassed some little
known city mayor or mp
he'd metaphorically pulled the pants
down on the entire british navy and if
there's one thing sailors don't like
it's having their pants pulled down
at least not metaphorically
understandably senior figures in the
navy were keen to have cole and his
accomplices arrested
but despite their antics
the group hadn't actually broken any
laws and so no conviction was possible
instead
in what might just have been the most
british punishment ever dished out the
hoaxes were subjected to
a symbolic thrashing of the buttocks by
royal navy officers
virginia woolf was the only one who was
spared a spanking
for all his brilliance as a prankster
coal wasn't quite so gifted when it came
to the important things in life
like his actual life his first wife left
him after he managed to lose his entire
fortune in a doomed real estate venture
and though his second wife did give cole
a son it turned out the child wasn't
actually coles but one of his close
friends a painter by the name of
augustus john
how's that for a prank
cole would die at the relatively young
age of 55 of a heart attack
as for hms dreadnought pride of the
british fleet
in 1915 she became the first and only
warship to ram and sink a german
submarine during the first world war the
navy received a deluge of congratulatory
telegrams for this remarkable
achievement
but perhaps the first one to arrive sums
defeat and this whole story up the best
it simply read
bunga bunga
thanks for watching
conflict of nations is a free online pvp
strategy game happening in a modern
global warfare setting so if you're
ready to choose your own strategy and
engage in epic battles then download
conflict of nations now it's free to
play and right now you can get an
exclusive gift by clicking on the link
in the description to get 13 000 gold
and one month of premium subscription
for free this off is only available for
30 days so don't miss out